[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video I
will be talking about the rising of the
shield hero a nui sekai anime that
premiered in the winter 2019 season from
the very first episode this anime was
followed by a ton of controversy
stemming primarily from the fact that a
number of reviewers from the anime news
network slammed the anime as soon as the
first episode came out to be clear I am
NOT saying that you have to like shield
hero and that if you don't you must be
stupid on the contrary there certainly
are some fair criticisms that can be
leveled against the show and I have a
few of them myself
however the unfounded claim that the
rising of the shield hero is offensive
and that it somehow condones the
mistreatment of women is just plain
stupid not stupid in the sense of having
a low IQ but stupid in the sense that
those who are making this claim appeared
to be willfully ignorant and
closed-minded to a troubling degree the
first episode follows now Fumi an otaku
college student as he is summoned into a
fantasy world where he must become one
of the four legendary heroes these
heroes are tasked with saving the
fantasy world from impending doom
however unlike the other three heroes
who used the sword the spear and the
bull was their weapons now Foom his
legendary weapon is the shield which
makes his abilities primarily defensive
and for this reason he is considered to
be the weakest out of all the heroes
much of the controversy surrounding the
series stems from the fact that in the
first episode now Fumi is perceived as
the weakest and most useless hero and no
one wants to join his party eventually
though a female character named mine
agrees to join the shield hero only to
end up tricking him by falsely accusing
him of sexual assault in order to rob
him of his valuables and discredit him
as a hero
in the eyes of the public now if this
was an academic paper I would name the a
and n reviewers in question and I would
link to their statements but because I
have a sizable platform here on YouTube
I don't want this video to be perceived
as an invitation to attack anyone on a
personal level for that reason alone I
will assign the reviewers a number
rather than using their real names
because I want to make it clear that I
am NOT inviting
to attack them I am making this video
simply to point out some of the blatant
flaws in their claims a NN reviewer
number one calls the fact that false
sexual assault allegations are used in
the story and I quote ethically dubious
and needlessly off-putting it's also
lazy storytelling whether it is lazy
storytelling is obviously debatable but
this is a good example of the kind of
criticism that shield hero received a NN
reviewer number two reminds us that it
is in fact of the current year when they
say it seems like an unbelievably bad
time to start an anime series with the
main character being falsely accused of
sexual assault that premise makes the
show seem tone-deaf and I imagine it'll
drive away some potential viewers keep
in mind that the reviewer says this
despite the fact that the shield hero
light novel began its run back in 2013
so in no way can the story be
interpreted as some sort of social
commentary on the me2 movement and in
the most blatant example of the
unfounded criticism that the anime has
received a and ed reviewer number 3
rated and I say rated in big quotation
marks the first episode and I quote burn
it and salt the earth this particular
reviewer went so far as to accuse the
author of the story of being and I quote
angry at women and called the first
episode itself a hollow shell of
masturbatory otaku reference Scrabble
rather than a review reviewer number
three's entire text reads more like an
angry rant that tries to infer the
author's deepest political and social
beliefs from a few scenes in the first
episode of a fictional cartoon and the
reviewer then hilariously accuses the
author and the main protagonist of being
too angry and jaded about the world
around them imagine calling someone else
angry after freaking out on the internet
over a fictional piece of work so much
so that you wanna klieg Eve the first
episode of rating of Burnett and salty
earth now since these claims were
initially made a number of people have
come out to claim that the author of
shield hero
Anna Kawasaki is actually a war
as far as I can tell there is no
official confirmation about the author's
gender but that only underscores how
malicious it is for a viewer number
three and others to imply that they know
the innermost feelings and beliefs of a
person when they actually know next to
nothing about that person gender
included but the truth is that the
gender of the author of the shield hero
doesn't even matter because if you are
able to restrain yourself from
pretentious virtue signaling for longer
than five minutes you can see that the
underlying message of the rising of the
shield hero is definitely not a hateful
one the reason that I didn't make this
video sooner is because I wanted to wait
for a number of episodes of the anime to
actually air before I made sweeping
judgments about the series and I am glad
that I did because regardless of the
author's gender or politics the actual
story of shield hero the thing that
matters the most is not a story of hate
or anger but of compassion and
overcoming adversity now it is
absolutely true that false sexual
assault allegations are rare and that
makes perfect sense
coming out and talking about something
as traumatizing as sexual assault is
incredibly difficult and know mentally
and emotionally stable person male or
female would ever want to put themselves
through that if the horrible event
didn't actually happen with that said
portraying a false accusation in a work
of fiction in no way implies that real
cases of sexual assault do not happen
and it will be completely unreasonable
to claim that the first episode of
shield hero is actively encouraging all
men to see all women as evil and
conniving this is the same logic that
claims that violent video games
encourage violence in real life it
implies that the viewers who watch the
anime and see this one evil female
character doing evil things will begin
to see all women in general as evil and
deceitful it is worth noting than in
shield hero there are far more male
characters who are shown in a negative
light than female characters including
the spear hero who is incredibly
gullible and full of himself the King
who plots against an innocent man the
men who insult and try to rob the shield
hero in the streets the male slave
trader and
many more the fact that one villainous
female character did something
villainous to a fictional male character
in an anime obviously does not mean that
all women are villains in the real world
both women and men have the potential to
be good people and a potential to be bad
people this is simply human nature and
the claim that one evil female character
who does evil things is representative
of the author's overall outlook on women
is both intellectually dishonest and
malicious this unfounded claim willfully
slanders the character and reputation of
the author despite the fact that next to
nothing is actually known about the
author can you imagine anything more
intellectually dishonest and malicious
than trying to slander and ruin the
reputation of someone you know next to
nothing about but with all of that said
I personally feel that the first episode
of shield hero was one of the weaker
episodes so far I say this because the
motivations of the spear hero the female
villain mine and the king are kind of
weak in my opinion this fantasy world is
facing an existential threat that only
the four legendary heroes can stop so
why in the world would the king and
other members of this kingdom conspire
to destroy one of the legendary heroes
thereby decreasing their own chances of
survival why would the spear hero be so
ready to believe every horrible thing
that he hears about the shield hero when
they were both just sent into this
unknown world together and it is logical
to assume that working together for a
common purpose would increase their
chances of actually surviving why in the
world did mine blatantly steal the
shield heroes silver coins and items if
she was presenting herself to be the
victim in the situation I did not get
the impression that these items were
exceptionally rare or hard to obtain
especially for the four legendary heroes
now it is true that the shield hero has
the reputation of being the weakest but
even with that in mind it has been
prophesized that only these four
legendary heroes can save mankind there
are four of them for a reason so the
idea that the king and the others were
under threat of total destruction would
decide to simply do away with one of the
legendary heroes who
surely did nothing wrong to any of them
doesn't make much sense to me
there could be an explanation for all of
this later on in the story in which case
I look forward to seeing it but these
were just my thoughts in terms of the
first episode itself however once the
betrayal happens and the shield hero is
cast out to wander the kingdom on his
own this story does become extremely
interesting and the message it conveys
is powerful the shield hero was summoned
into this fantasy world through no fault
of his own he was never given a choice
and then instead of being respected and
adorned he was betrayed shunned and
mocked at this point he does become
angry and jaded and he decides that the
only way to survive is to be hard on the
world that has been so hard on him he
forces merchants to be fair to him
instead of ripping him off with the
threat of violence he doesn't hesitate
to use underhanded tactics to protect
himself from potential attack and after
he realizes that he cannot gain
experience in advance as a hero without
someone handling the offensive element
of battles he decides to purchase a
slave to do the attacking for him some
critics of the anime have accused it of
literally promoting slavery because of
this event in the story but in the
fantasy world in which the shield hero
was forced to come against his will
enslaving deme humans who are part human
and part animal is considered completely
acceptable at least by a large segment
of the population now who me the shield
hero after being framed robbed and
shunned by everyone in a dangerous and
unfamiliar world decides that the only
way to survive in this world is to play
by the rules of that world he decides to
do whatever it takes to survive even if
that means giving the inhabitants of
that world a taste of their own bitter
medicine however as soon as the shield
hero buys a sickly demi-human girl
called ruff Talia he instantly feels
compassion towards her in spite of
himself he goes out of his way to cure
her illness and to comfort her as she
deals with tragic flashbacks of losing
her parents and being forced into
slavery despite the fact that he may be
better off just being cruel to others as
they had been cruel to him the shield
hero cannot help but feel compassion for
ruff Talia he mentors her helps her grow
and develop as both a fighter and a
person and he goes out of his way
to make her happy when he is later
accused of enslaving and mistreating
raff Thalia by the spear hero ruff
Thalia defends the shield hero because
she has come to both trust him and care
for him and just a side note isn't it
ironic that this anime is being accused
of promoting sexism when the main
character literally has a woman fighting
his battles for him
a woman who also happens to be a great
character someone who is brave kind and
has impressive combat skills it is clear
to me personally that the rising of the
shield hero is not a story about hate or
anger
if you bother to give the show more than
a few minutes of your time you quickly
realize that the true message of shield
hero is the importance of being brave in
the face of extremely difficult odds and
the undeniable power of basic human
compassion no amount of hate lies and
mockery could make now for me the shield
hero hateful and jaded enough to numb
his natural sense of compassion for a
fellow human being despite the fact that
ruff Thalia is labeled a slave and
despite the fact that she is considered
to be less than human in this particular
society the shield hero cannot bring
himself to treat her poorly even though
he was made to suffer by others he can't
bring himself to just take his
frustrations out on another innocent
person the message that I got from the
rising of the shield hero is this
sometimes in life we come across bad
people these bad people can be male or
female and because of these bad people
we may find ourselves facing extremely
difficult odds but even if we find
ourselves in such an unfortunate
situation we cannot and must not forget
the importance of compassion we cannot
allow ourselves to succumb to injustice
and we must not allow ourselves to
become as bad as the people who
mistreated us we have to be brave
stubborn clever and we have to persevere
and we always have to remember that even
with all the evil in the world there are
also many good people out there innocent
people who might also be suffering and
struggling we cannot allow ourselves to
become so jaded that we would mistreat
these innocent people in the same way
that we were mistreated by others and
just like the shield hero every rational
person knows that enslaving another
human being
is wrong even if they look different
than we do or have a different social
status than we do
our basic sense of empathy and
compassion for our fellow human beings
will lead us to the truth and just like
the shield hero we must listen to our
heart and do the right thing even if
that same level of compassion was not
granted to us by others life is not
always fair and we will not always be
treated fairly by others and yeah that
sucks
but this does not mean that we should
give up and become as bad as the people
who have treated us badly on the
contrary we should stubbornly fight
against injustice and we should treat
others with compassion even when we are
told that these others are allegedly
different from us or beneath us socially
this in my opinion is the true message
of the shield hero anime thus far and
all those individuals who jumped to
judge this series and even the author of
the series based on their own biased
interpretation of the first episode have
said more about themselves than I could
ever say here they have demonstrated the
same willfully ignorant and intolerant
behavior that the villains of the story
have demonstrated towards the shield
hero and it is nothing short of poetic
justice that the shield hero's
perseverance and compassion against all
odds is winning over so many anime fans
across the world while those who
unfairly criticized the shield hero both
the character and the series have been
repudiated by the wider anime community
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more videos like it you can leave
a like to let me know if you're new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification valve if you
want to talk more about the shield hero
or maybe you have some ideas for future
videos feel free to hit me up on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar and
finally I want to say a big thank you to
everyone who has been supporting anime
up or on patreon both now and in the
past if you want to support more content
on this channel feel free to check out
our patreon page linked in the
description as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see you space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]